bonjour jean marc sylvestre merci d'être
avec nous alors quels sont les secteurs
où les choses vont bien se passer et les
secteurs ou au contraire cela risque
d'être douloureux écoutez c'est vrai que
tout les secteurs et toutes les
entreprises sont pas logés à la même
enseigne dans dans cette opération c'est
vrai quand même globalement l'ambiance a
changé les magasins sont ouverts les
cafés les restaurants
plus qu'un symbole sont très fréquentés
depuis 24 heures
appuyé en plus il fait beau et puis
surtout surtout je crois que l'élément
clé sont les chiffres sur les tables de
d'épidémie qui s'améliore donc l'
angoisse qui paralysait un peu tous les
consommateurs est peut-être en train de
disparaître simplement dans la réalité
il ya des secteurs qui vont bien et des
secteurs qui iront encore mal pendant
tout l'été et peut-être davantage ne
serait ce que dans le secteur des cafés
restaurants par exemple je crois qu'il
ya trois catégories vous avez des cafés
restaurants qui ont une terrasse
notamment dans paris qui vont s'en
sortir ils peuvent respecter toutes les
normes sanitaires normes d'hygiène et
les autres tous les petits restaurants
de quartier qui sont trop petits pour le
faire il risque d'avoir énormément de
mal je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
réouvert et je suis pas sûr qu'ils vont
ouvrir avant la rentrée les restaurants
et les hôtels qui sont moyenne gamme
les clubs de vacances les campings vont
pouvoir réussir leur saison touristique
notamment avec la clientèle française en
vol vous avez aussi tout l'établissement
très chic et très cher qui se déplacent
par exemple qui vont avoir du mal parce
que la clientèle étrangère
elle va pas venir les hommes d'affaires
ne vont pas venir non plus puisqu'ils
sont pas des tentes et des travaillent
pour la plupart donc au global
vous avez en gros quatre cent mille
établissements vous en avez 30 % qui
vont sans doute pas rouvrir ou qui vont
même disparaître à la fin de l'été ça
fait qu en gros 120 me en tout avec deux
ou trois heures debout à chacun
par maison en moyenne ça fait encore
presque et 308 chômeurs de plus
inquiétant voyez-vous n'est pas là le
plus inquiétant est bien ce dieu dans
les secteurs industriels on a vu le
mobile de l'aéronautique le transport
aérien et pourtant tous ces secteurs ont
reçu des aides importantes alors comment
se fait-il qu'il soit encore menacée
ils ont reçu et ça va d'ailleurs
continuer avec le secteur de
l'aéronautique cette semaine c'est très
sympa les constructeurs automobiles ont
pas vendu une voiture depuis trois mois
alors l'état a évidemment inonder le
marché de primes en toutes sortes mais
on ne peut pas obliger les clients même
si les clients du pouvoir d'achat à
acheter une nouvelle voiture
s'il joue l'angoissent du chômage et ils
ont on peut pas désobliger non plus à
acheter par exemple mais une voiture
électrique
donc ça va être compliqué dans le
transport aérien
c'est un peu pareil dans le transport
aérien pour celui des normes sanitaires
les prix vont forcément augmenter alors
il ya des compagnes et très bien
organisée qui resteront en vol et low
cost par exemple vont sans doute sur
sortir mais vous en avez d'autres qui
vont mourir même phénomène dans
l'industrie aéronautique
on ne vend plus d'avions airbus ne vend
plus d'avions eh bien vous avez toute la
filière les fournisseurs et les
sous-traitants qui vont trinquer c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
s'est emparé de ce dossier pour pour
jauzion il va donc y avoir des
défaillances d'entreprises et des
licenciements wee aa après la vague de
chômage partiel qui a été relativement
bien gérer un
depuis le début de la crise on s'attend
en septembre à une deuxième vague de
licenciements cette fois-ci licenciement
assez massif nous avons déjà
actuellement près de 5 millions de
chômeurs inscrits certains en prévoir un
million et demi de plus et surtout les
jeunes pourquoi parce que les
entreprises ont coupé on le voit bien
tous les contrats d'apprentissage
ils ont coupé les contrats en alternance
et jeunes ont beaucoup de mal à trouver
des jobs et notamment à la nouvelle
génération qui va arriver là sur le
marché attend ça va être une génération
qu'ovide les entreprises fragiles elles
ne vont pas tenir
elle était déjà fragile avant le combiné
ça c'est très important
alors elles vont survivre vous raconter
les organisations patronales que le
virus les a tuées
mais en réalité m
j'étais malade avant c'est un peu comme
dans la population humaine locaux vides
a été très violent pour les personnes à
risque les personnes cardiaques
diabétiques âgés et bien dans
l'industrie c'est la même chose la crise
sanitaire va tuer en septembre les
entreprises les plus vulnérables celles
qui sont par ni protégé ni réforme merci
beaucoup jean marc sylvestre pour toutes
ces précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et éditorialiste économique